president biden's got big problems a
majority of americans think his
administration is incompetent and things
are about to get much worse inflation is
surging like wildfire all across the
country the massive rise in prices is
costing american households an extra 175
dollars a month and gas prices are the
highest in seven years the white house
forced to spin the bad news on rising
prices at the pump
as you said
some ticks up in in parts of the country
that's something we've been working to
focus on certainly we all want to keep
gasoline prices low uh but uh the threat
of the crisis uh the climate crisis
certainly can't wait any longer ah
okay i'll start with you harold all
right the the gas prices are the highest
that they've been in seven years and the
average family now paying more than 175
a month for the cost of inflation is
going to get worse in 2022
um
why do the democrats want to spend more
money won't that create a bigger problem
so i have a different different view on
this i think that the economy prior to
covet was facing some of these strains i
think our economy has been organized the
last 30 years
around efficiency so you have investors
who want to make sure you don't make
more than what you need in any sphere of
life including an energy then we have
covet and everything explodes we try our
hardest to figure out how we answer
things we spend money the fed spends
money so i think we have an or we have
an organ of government the fed that can
try to address some of this i actually
think we should be figuring out ways to
spend more money in the on the right
things including including how do we
improve supply chains i think supply
chains across the world
those constraints those restraints are
causing prices to go up all across the
board and there's an argument to be made
that we may be spending more than we
should on certain things but i think if
we want five to ten years from now not
to face these kind of pressures energy
pressures durable good pressures
semi-conductor chip pressures we have to
figure out how do we invest in ways to
help america build more of these and
make us less reliant on those overseas
when we depend on to produce them for us
well you know jesse target and home
depot are now chartering their own ships
so that they can deliver billions of
dollars of products to get in time get
here in time for christmas i mean is it
just supply chain or what else is going
on well if we hadn't offshored every
single factory in this country to asia
we wouldn't have a huge supply chain
issue also exacerbating that there's a
trucker shortage so even if you get the
ship containers on shore there's no one
there to drive them to any of these
stores so that's not all biden's fault
but part of it also
if you're going to spend what is it
going to be if these two bills go
through about 12 trillion in one single
fiscal year that's just going to make
u.s dollar into like whatever the
zimbabwe currency is we do not want that
what is it zimbabwe i don't know but
it's probably like one trillionth of a
dollar um so not all of it's biden's
fault but he's making it worse and the
biggest mistake joe biden made was in
the spring to dismiss inflation yeah he
said oh this is just transitory it's
gonna go away now he's supposed to be
amtrak joe mr scranton he's supposed to
have his ear to the street with the
middle class and to dismiss it like that
and then to make a mockery of the hot
dog crisis on july 4th makes him look
totally out of touch while the average
middle-class family only making 67
thousand dollars a year is now paying an
extra 175 dollars in cost of living
because of this inflation all right so
so dana
they're talking about granholm the
energy secretary's talking about tapping
the energy uh uh the reserve of the oil
you know what every administration tries
it it doesn't work that's right and it's
there for emergencies and so they should
really just set that aside
what what the press secretary said today
um we we want to keep gas prices low but
the threat of climate change crisis it
can't wait any longer there will be tens
of millions if not hundreds of millions
of dollars in ads that are you that use
that exact quote in the next year to
deal with uh
going into the midterms the other thing
is the indelible images of afghanistan
and what happened
in that debacle as we left americans
behind and the people who helped us
behind and just the chaos and the way
that it was handled
all of those images have had a lasting
impression and it's seeping into all the
other numbers some of the if you just
peek under the hood of some of these
poll numbers
on this military
his numbers handling terrible as
commander in chief his competency has
and and now you have the other poll and
gallup saying that people think uh the
republicans would be better on national
security yeah and it's only october yeah
national security uh uh greg as well as
the economy mm-hmm 100 trillion zimbabwe
dollars
will fetch only 40 cents no is that
incredible no way
but a the central bank introduced the 50
note uh
as the main currency in 2019 and then
you had hyperinflation toward 800
percent so there you go i mean he is
killing the dollar he is killing he's
just killing the dollar no he's
destroying zimbabwe is what he's doing
goes to your to your point it goes back
to um kind of the selfish reason so many
people voted for biden
they didn't care that a president trump
improved in these concrete variables you
know the low inflation uh foreign policy
uh in in the and the vaccines but
because uh late night trump gave you
early morning anxiety through tweets he
had to go so what we're now we're we're
bearing
the the consequences of an emotional
decision made by a lot of people because
again you can't if you look at the
variables of covet the economy uh
foreign policy
trump the border trump trump blows biden
away which is why when you look at the
media
it's going to be from here on in january
6th january 6th because you can't it's
it's scott adams pointed this out
i've done that all right they can't you
know what's great they can't compare the
four years of trump the four years
divided they're using something that
happened after
one day because all of the other
variables cannot be did you see where
they have the facebook whistleblowers
yes testifying
total totals
all right i had liberal police policies
unleashing mayhem on innocent americans
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else